[Music]
Good for Guji Anke a Yes,
that's right, it's instant Greek yogurt that's concentrated by draining 8
bills and when you remove the moisture, the
new ingredients are condensed and a gentle country like cheese is born I whipped it with egg whites
It's mixed in the soufflé batter, and as a
result, the brown sugar bean paste, which is the main ingredient,
makes it even more appealing to Koreans.
It's
easy to handle and has excellent filtration performance.
It's the best choice for draining water with this product
.
When I used ricotta cheese and cream cheese, I
was sure of my origins,
just as Shushigaku said.
Mr. Tadokoro couldn't make this product unless he saw the challenging dorayaki.
And glass means grace in French
[music]